- [Voiceover] What I'd
like to do in this video
is give you an overview of the
Khan Academy SAT resources.
The official SAT resources that
we've been able to construct
alongside with our partners
at the college board.
So right when you go to the resource,
it'll ask you a few questions.
The first one is "Are
you trying to practice
"for the SAT or the PSAT?"
The tests are obviously
related but then this will help
the system just know what
you're actually trying to target
and in the first version of this,
it's primarily about SAT but that's still
going to help you for the PSAT.
That says next to question two.
I got to answer four questions here.
The SAT is changing in March 2016.
Which SAT do you want to practice for?
The current SAT, the new
SAT, or I'm not sure.
Let's say I want to do the new SAT.
And then we'd like to
be able to let you know
about upcoming SAT events in your area,
such as Saturday in-person practice tests
and local study groups.
This is actually something
we're very excited about
and of course, we're never going to
sell your personal information.
It's just to notify you when
interesting things are going on.
So I could put in my ZIP
code right over there
and then, question four:
Our system will create a personalized plan
that focuses you on practicing
the skills you need to improve the most.
It's going to start me on
four short diagnostic quizzes
that should each take
about ten minutes each
and says where do I
want to focus on first.
Let's just say I want
to focus more on math.
Let's do this thing.
So here we are.
We said we wanted to focus on math first
and you see there's two tabs.
There's reading and writing
and then there's math.
It defaulted me to math because that's
what I said I want to focus on first
and then we see here that there are,
that there are four
quizzes that I could take.
Each of them should take
me roughly 10 minutes.
They're going to have 10 questions on them
and the goal of these, and I encourage you
to kind of take the time out to do these
as well as you can.
Don't just kind of guess the answers
because this will inform the system
where you are at different skills.
The goal of doing four
quizzes with 10 questions each
is by doing these 40 questions,
you're essentially covering
all of the major dimensions
that you might see on a math SAT
and so the system will be able to say,
"Okay, what are you stronger at
"and what are you weaker at?"
And it will be able to give
you personalized practice.
Let's take one of these quizzes
just to see what it looks like.
And so it says the quiz is not timed.
We'll assign you a starting strength
for every skill on the quiz.
It says calculators are not allowed
and once again, this is
all for your benefit,
to get a sense of what you
know and what you don't know.
And like on the new SAT,
there's no penalty for guessing.
So let's start, let's start this quiz.
Alright, so I'm gonna kind of pseudo try
and answer some of
these and a few of them,
I might just guess just
for the sake of time.
Slema is filling her water jugs
with spring water at the supermarket.
The above equation gives the empty space
in her jugs, V, in US
gallons after T minutes
at a constant fill rate.
How many minutes will it
take to fill the jugs?
So let's think about it.
When the jugs are filled,
there's not going to be any empty space
so this is going to be equal to zero.
So what time will make V equal zero?
You have no empty space left.
Well, time would be 6.4.
So after 6.4 minutes,
so let me type that in.
6.4, let's finish this diagnostic.
And what do we have?
All right, well we get a report
and on this report, we see
that I was able to get nine
out of the 10 questions right.
For the ones that I was able to get right,
I'm going to start at skill level 3.
What is skill level 3, you ask?
Well, we've broadly been able to chunk
the types of items that
you've seen on the SAT
into three skill levels:
Skill level 2, skill level
3, and skill level 4.
You might say, "Well what
is skill level 1, then?"
Well, skill level 1 would be
the pre-requisite knowledge
that you might not actually see on the SAT
but if you're having
trouble with skill level 2,
we have resources that will allow you
to build those foundations
in that pre-requisite work.
But you saw the things that I got right,
linear equality word problems,
linear function word problems,
operations with polynomials.
The system is now going to say,
"Hey Sal, I'm going to start you
"at a higher skill
level, at skill level 3,
"which is not the most challenging,
"but the second most challenging level
"because you got everything,
"you got these right here."
And you can see that
here in this little dial
right over here where
three out of the four
are filled in but I got one wrong
and as far as the system knows,
well hey, maybe we'll start you at
a slightly less challenging level for
interpreting non-linear expressions
because of that one there.
But if I want to say hey, I
feel like I got this one right,
let me see why I got it wrong,
I can review my answers.
So I click review answers.
I got that one right.
And this was the wrong,
this was the one that we got wrong.
So not only does it
show me what I selected
but it tells me why it is wrong.
We would use vertex form to
reveal the maximum/minimum.
This model has a minimum.
And it tells us what the answer is.
The right answer was this
right over here, was C.
And we could review the
rest of our questions
or we could just exit the diagnostic.
And now once we exit the diagnostic,
we can take more of the quizzes.
Once again, I encourage
you to take the time out
to properly do these quizzes.
Have some scratch paper in hand
so you can give your best shot at 'em,
so you can give the best
information to the system
so it can give you the best
recommendations afterwards.
After you've finished these four quizzes,
then the system is ready to
start recommending things to you
and so this is what it will look like
after you've finished your four quizzes.
And you see these four,
I guess you could call them activities
are things that the system thinks
that you can work on.
So data collection and conclusions.
And notice right here, it has,
this is just this one bolded up.
If we click on this one,
then that one gets bolded up on top.
If we click on that one,
that one gets bolded up on top.
And it says this is the
system's current best guess
of the skill level that I'm at,
that I'm at two out of four.
Now I'm going to practice.
If I click on practice these skills,
then I'm actually going
to get exercises in them.
And if I were to get,
if I were to get them right,
then I'm more likely to be promoted
to start working on
more challenging skills.
And so the whole idea here is that
I'm always able to work on the skills
and the difficulty level
or the challenge level
that is appropriate to keep me
getting better all the time.
It doesn't help you if
you're working on stuff
that you already know really well
and it doesn't help you
if you're working on stuff
that you have a lot of trouble with.
You're best working on the stuff
that you have a decent chance of getting
but you're still struggling
with a little bit.
That's what's going to
improve you the most.
Now these three are just
standard practice sections,
I guess you would say,
and this one over here
is a timed mini-session.
It says calculators okay so you can get
your calculator out for this one.
And this one is to kind of give you a mini
kind of a practice under a
little bit of time pressure
because obviously when
you take the standard,
the SAT or really any standardized test,
you're going to be under time pressure
and so this will let you practice under,
under those conditions.
Now, if you scroll down,
if you scroll down,
you can see that there's
all this stuff down here.
What is this?
Well up here, this is
what the system thinks
that you're best off working on
but it also recognizes hey,
you might have in your own mind the things
that you want to work on most.
and so that's what you can pick over here,
heart of algebra, and it
gives all the subtopics there,
passport to advanced mathematics.
It gives all the subjects there.
It gives the best read
on how much you have,
what level you are at each of these.
And you can either click right over here
and get practice problems
in that exact section
or you could click on the videos
to see example videos in that,
in that, in that topic.
And if you click on easier,
it's going to give you an easier example.
If you click on harder,
it's going to give you
a video of a harder example.
So that's what's, and you just,
I'm going to ideally
just keep working on that
a little bit every day so you keep
getting better and better,
do a lot of deliberate practice
and really kind of build your muscles
in the areas where you
might be less familiar.
And once again, all of this is stuff
that you will have seen in school
and so a lot of this
might be review for you
or filling in gaps that you might have
not filled in the first time
that you saw it in school.
Now that's on the math.
That's only part of the SAT.
We also have a very similar thing
for the reading and writing.
So once again, you have
your diagnostic quizzes
like we mentioned
and after that, it'll give
you suggested practice.
And just to see what it looks like,
we can check and go down to see
what these things look like,
say on writing argument.
You can see that it actually
matches very similar
to the form factor that you
would actually see on the SAT
so that when you actually
take it in real life,
you are familiar with kind of what,
hey, what does this one
with a dark box on it mean?
Well, you'd be familiar with it
when you take the actual SAT
but you have your, you have your passages
or your sentence correction
right over there.
And so that's math, that's
reading and writing.
Those are kind of your two main dashboards
for practicing and doing
deliberate practice.
If you want some kind of high
level things about the SAT,
you can go to tips and planning
and then you can click
on any of these videos
or read some of these articles.
And then if you want real
full-length practice exams,
you click up over here.
And you see these complete practice exams
and these, I encourage you to really take
as much time out as necessary
to simulate real test-taking conditions
because this is where you're going to,
well you'll take these, simulate the test,
get practice in that,
and then that's also
going to give information
to the system on what
you need to work on more
so you could take these practice exams
just kind of with a
standard paper and pencil
but the value of taking it on this system
is after you take it,
one, it will be auto-graded
but on top of that,
that information of what you got wrong
and what you got right will be used
to give you better guidance
and give you better practice.
So anyway, there's a lot
to think about just now
but hopefully you find this as valuable
or as fun as some of us do
and good luck with everything.